hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast titled create your own
cellular compound target engagement
assay presented by Dana Haley Vicente
PhD senior product manager discover X
corporation we are excited to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by lab roots the leading scientific
social networking websites and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
this webinar is sponsored by discover ex
discover ex is an innovative company
that develops manufactures and
commercializes reagents complete
cell-based assay kits profiling and
screening services as well as other
turnkey based solutions to the drug
discovery and life science markets their
bio chemical is cell-based assay
platforms enable researchers to improve
the productivity and effectiveness of
their screening lead optimization and
SAR campaigns thus accelerating the
discovery and development of new drugs
I'm julissa Morozov labrys and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
before we start the presentation we have
a few important announcements to make we
welcome your questions during the
webinar
since attendees will be muted during the
presentation please submit any questions
by typing your questions into the
questions box which may be located near
the bottom of your control panel
following the presentation we will
address any questions that were
submitted in the order in which they
were received if we run over the hour
allotted and do not address your
question we will personally answer your
question by email following the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credit now I'd like to
introduce dr. Dana Haley Vicente
dr. Hanley Vicente is currently a senior
product manager at discover X managing
Selva based
FAs kits and consumable products for
target discovery screening lead
optimization and SAR campaigns she has
been working in the drug discovery
industry for over 16 years and received
her PhD in pharmacology from the
University of California Los Angeles
please join me in welcoming dr. Hanley
Vicente I will now turn the presentation
over to her Thank You Julie and thank
you everyone for joining today's seminar
is creating your own cellular target
engagement assay so this is more like a
DIY or Do It Yourself type of seminar so
let's get started we have our agenda
we'll be going over what is cellular
target engagement and going over some
key aspects of the assays needed then
we'll dive right into the specific tools
and now these are in-house tools you can
purchase their vector based tools to
create your own target engagement assays
and this section I'll introduce you to
the technology behind this the N cell
pulse technology then we'll dive deep
into the experimental designs and
workflows so this is the main point of
the presentation and then end up with a
few applications and a case study
focusing on kinases and methyl
transferases hydrolases etc and then
finish up with a summary slide and QA
all right so small molecule drugs in
general they work by acting on protein
targets and eliciting a desirable
phenotype so this is a core concept of
pharmacology and it many times it's very
difficult to get at so we know wouldn't
it be nice to determine if your specific
compound
directly engage to your correct target
in the cell so we have a picture here
showing you the basic concept of
cellular target engagement it's a very
simple concept describing the cartoon or
the image as a small molecule compound
it's not work looking at biologics such
as antibodies or large proteins because
a small molecule compound needs to be
able to enter the cell and then bind or
engage
to this so-called intracellular protein
target of interest historically though
in general this has been difficult to
measure correctly
you know without functional type of
assays or phenotypic assays and current
biochemical type of assays for target
engagement typically lack the ability to
determine whether that compound you know
can penetrate through that cell membrane
so also in general compound binding and
the majority of cases causes a change or
alters the thermodynamic stability of
that protein so binding will actually
change the observed steady state levels
and what I mean by steady state levels
it's the change between a degradation
and the synthesis of your specific
target you're looking at so in most
cases it will the binding will allow it
to increase the levels of target protein
due to this possible you know stable
stabilization effect all right so let's
bring this into context to the drug
discovery world you're looking at
different approaches here and a drug
discovery continuum and where would
target engagement play a role so first
of all target specific approach this is
the top portion of the slide you start
out with a target specific biochemical
screen for instance you have like 500
targets or Suniya chemicals that you
want to look at you identify them and
then you follow this up show or prove
that they have some kind of target
specific cellular activity so you may
use cellular assays like a functional
based ones or maybe an indirect
phenotypic FA this is also a nice place
for target engagement assays where they
would be applied and then once this is
established compounds can then be tested
in a more you know complex cellular
animal model to validate the target and
the compound drug like properties the
second approach a little less common but
you may start out with a phenotypic
screen perhaps a cell based assays
screening against the compound compound
library you identify hits that give you
that specific desirable phenotype then
perform you know
target convolution studies which
sometimes can be very difficult but you
want to answer what is the target of my
compound that is giving me this specific
phenotypic or this effect and this tends
to deliver some really good hypothesis
which then obviously need to be tested
and validated and that's where target
engagement could be introduced you prove
that the compound will actually engage
with that specific intended target in
the cellular context and in this data
will help you know validate the target
in general so these are two key areas
where cellular target engagement
athletes can be applied in the drug
discovery continuum all right so now
getting back into the lab so we are a
customer and we would like to use a
target engagement assay system so what
are the needs of our customers the main
need is obviously is my compound cell
penetrant so that's the first bullet
point in the blue box or the indented
one so ensures your compound gets into
the cell and they want to show that the
compound actually binds or engages with
this specific target that's intended you
may also want to rank order how potent
your specific compounds are against the
target you may want to confirm target
engagement for a specific target that
you believe is responsible for a
particular phenotype of the cells that
are treated as I mentioned on the last
slide but overall the specific assay
requirements is customers want something
quantitative easy-to-use and an in-house
type of solution it's very flexible
ability to do high-throughput type of
approaches they definitely want at low
cost and very generic they want to use
their own targets and obviously
compounds without any need for custom
reagents and obviously give you accurate
results so those are the main
requirements or assay needs and discover
X has
wanted to create a solution for all
these asset needs but it first started
out with a few years few years ago there
was a breakthrough with the introduction
of cell based thermals to the
stabilisation assays and these are
called thermal shift assays they're
powerful concept of thermal stability
changes like induces the ligand binding
to demonstrate that the ligand is
actually bound to the target so let's
look at the first graph the lower
left-hand corner this is a concept where
your cells are actually being heated at
increasing high temperatures you're
looking at the black curve in this first
graph and that's showing you the target
protein actually denatures or aggregates
as the cells are being increased in
temperature but if a line is bound for
instance this is now the red curve so
the ligand goes into the cell and it
starts to be heated with the system
temperature required to be nature the
protein these proteins are actually the
temperature is shifted to the right so
the proteins can withstand a higher
temperature now this concept can be
exploited to then use you know an
isothermic type of approach as a
function of the compound at different
temperatures or excluding different
concentrations and measured at inhibitor
potencies so the current methods you
know they may take advantage of
traditional type of technologies Western
blot Eliza like mass spec type of
approaches we're made they may require
custom antibodies some other approaches
may require chemical probes etc to value
but we've introduced at Discoverer X the
new technology called in cell pulls and
this does take the current thermal shift
assay type of technology into account
and this new product uses engineered
cells the acids definitely are very
simple and rapid easy to use they're
also homogeneous so no wash steps you
know unlike typical like Eliza's for
instance they are generic so you can use
this technology to evaluate a diverse
set of
targets their high throughput and
quantitative and the readout is very
simple it's a chemiluminescent readout
allowing you to measure this target
engagement without the needs for
antibodies or mass spec or chemical
probes all right so overall you will
obtain melting temperature shift data
isothermic experiments will be performed
you'll get EC 50s signal the background
noise R ratios etc so let's move into
the tools to help you create your own
target engagement assays so introducing
you to the tools I first wanted to show
you know what is the you know the
technology that is behind in cell pulse
and you may have heard of this it's from
Discoverer X about in this from the
early 2000s it's called the enzyme
fragment complementation technology and
basically it's using a beta
galactosidase enzyme this enzyme has
been broken up into two fragments a very
small enzyme donor fragment this is that
little red squiggly line called pro
label so think of this as your enzyme
donor and then there's a larger fragment
called the enzyme acceptor now that's
that gray structure in the middle of the
slide together they form a you know
active enzyme but when they're apart
they're inactive and this allows you
when they're inactive you can take your
small pro label and bind it to your
target of interest and then with the
addition of the enzyme acceptor these
two now can combine and form an active
enzyme and then with the presence of a
substrate which is hydrolyzed and then
this produces a kami luminous
chemiluminescence signal that is read
out and gives you a nice signal on a
dose-response curve so in general the
small peptide it doesn't interfere with
your protein at all as far as
structurally it's very sensitive
detection for properly folded target
proteins you can think of it as like a
biochemical tag
census the folding state of the protein
so for instance if the protein is
denatured or aggregates in any way due
to temperature in our case this causes
for poor complementation they don't bind
together and results the readout is
reduced or decreased chemiluminescence
all right so if we add one more variable
into the scene we're going to add the
heat denaturation part and put it into
context of the cell first you start out
with your engineered cell line
expressing your protein target tagged
with a pro label that little red
squiggly line and then you introduce
your compound to the cell and perform
heat denaturation this is done by a PCR
machine and this allows you to you know
customize the assay parameters how many
seconds or minutes do you heat it up and
at what temperature excited will go over
that during the design of the experiment
all right so now if the compound that
you introduce does not bind so we're
looking at the lower right-hand part of
the image there is no target engagement
and that protein denatures and
aggregates complementation is
inefficient and you get that reduction
of the signal so less of the small Pro
label tag binds with a large EA or
enzyme X acceptor now its approach or
the compound does bind you're looking at
the upper right side of the image there
is target engagement and this is due to
protein is stabilized and precludes the
aggregation that's what the introduction
of the EA and the detection substrate
complementation occurs and you get the
chemiluminescence signal the readout and
a dose response type of manner alright
so what are the tools you need as I
mentioned earlier it is a vector-based
product that you can use to make your
assays in-house be creative as you'd
like the assay to develop this is takes
you no less than two weeks but this is
of course after the cloning step that is
required you have complete control over
this cell line that you want to use you
know use your favorite one you 2os choke
a one heck 293 etc then of course you
choose the protein of interest that
you'd like and the compounds of interest
and then you design it transient
transfection works well no need to build
stable cell lines at the beginning
before you're developing your assay
because all the testing is done you know
just prior to that what comes with the
product or this is called a starter pack
or a starter kit includes the vectors so
those are the key components you have
two different Pro label vectors so you
can tag your protein at the end or
c-terminus with this per label tag you
have a positive control vector this is
called mth one and this is just a
hydrolase and we'll go over how this is
used in the next couple of slides
you should definitely run this in
parallel with your experiments to make
sure everything is working properly then
you have the detection reagents these
are the e FC reagents including the
substrate enough to allow about 400 data
points and you have the plates we
provide those that can work both in the
PCR machine for the denaturation step as
well as the luminometer and then control
reagents are the ones to help you make
sure your assay is optimized all right
so let's now move into the experimental
design we're looking at a flow chart on
the right how to do the assay
development steps this is just a high /
high level overview first starting with
the cloning and transfection steps so
that sections 1 & 2 and then moving into
the main acid development sections so
there's three different phases I'll go
over those in the next couple of slides
and then finally ending up with the
creation of your stable cell light all
right so let's get going we're going to
talk about the experimental design and
workflow and go into these steps in a
little more detail all right so the
first phase let's see it's cloning and
trans section so the goal of this step
is to add the EPL or the pro label tag
to the seer and terminus of your target
protein and spread expression construct
and transect so we definitely provide
the vectors for this you could take your
target it could be full-length or it
could be just a specific domain for
instance the catalytic domain binds you
know the ATP domain binding side of a
kinase for instance you want to do the
cloning step and then the transient
transfection which takes place over
about three days
plating transfection and harvesting and
here you're looking at an example of one
of the vector Maps the cloning will
obviously be done at the MCS site or
multiple cloning site and you see there
is a EPL tag there with a small or a
short linker TeV between them and that
allows you to do the trans transection
all right the next phase gets into the
main assay development phases so there's
three of them this is the first of the
three that you perform after the
transfection and the goal of this is to
basically determine the variables that
will be used for your es c based
detection part of the assay so basically
identify the conditions that will be
used to ensure you get a very high
signal the background ratio and a
protocol kind of show that slows as
followed on the slide you want to
obviously design the plate layout do the
preparation and harvesting of yourself
and assemble the assays you know
multiple EFC detection solution
conditions set up basically to test
multiple conditions at this point so
that's why it's in blue it's the most
important part of this this step then
you want to perform the insult post
detection reagent or reaction read it
analyze the data and then based on this
data you will select the specific EFC
detection solution conditions
and these variables will be held
constant going forward we have some
guidelines also in the user manual that
is available online if you would like to
read it at any time I'll have a link for
you at the end alright so let's move
into the second phase of the essay
development process this is the goal
this is to identify thermal denaturation
temperatures okay so you want to show
that your Ligon is bound to your protein
and it makes a shift to the right
indicating that it is bound so let's the
first step is to perform you know the
melting temperature curve for the
protein target generated in the presence
or the absence of your inhibitor and so
you can kind of look at this figure on
the right it is the same one that I
showed earlier is much smaller than so
this is much easier to read you see now
that you heat yourself at increasing
temperatures for instance from thirty
seven to sixty degrees Celsius without
the ligand that is the black curve the
matter of vfc signal that we get
decreases pretty steeply as a function
of the temperature due to the
denaturation or the aggregation of the
target protein and therefore EFC is
becoming less and less efficient okay
then next you have you add your ligands
and the spines to your target you're
looking at the red curve now and you see
a TMZ that horizontal blue line in the
middle of the graph and then you see
that the target is still it does
denature but at higher temperatures this
time so at any given temperature for
instance around 50 degrees Celsius there
is an assay window and this is your
signal to background ratio so you know
if you take you titrate your compound in
you know looking at different
concentrations you can start with as
much signal and as a function of the
compound concentration to get to this
specific highest signal so again the
goal is to use a known coat inhibitor at
this step so I suggest you know use an
inhibitor that you identified by a
biochemical screen for example and that
will allow you to get this TM shift and
there's also some control experiment
that you will perform to evaluate the
compounds effects and the details again
are in the user manual for that alright
next step oh this is just the same phase
two but it goes over the protocol steps
in a little bit more detail it's very
similar to the last phase one except for
preparing the positive control you want
to stick with a single concentration at
this point and then during the setup you
want to treat yourselves you know with
the compound as well as me you know a
DMSO type of control don't forget that
you know do a range of temperatures for
the posting a tration step you know the
thermal gradient that's highlighted and
blue in this slide you want to use
obviously a thermal specular or PCR
machine you know set up your plate one
plate added to one PCR machine for a
single run your cells are in suspension
with the compound at this time you've
performed the detection reaction and
then analyze the data and choose the
temperatures for the next step so that's
the main goal so in this graph you see
that we looked at the control vector
that was created so nth is bounded Pro
label this hydrolase we ran the
experiment you know we want to run it in
parallel with the one that we're target
of interest the black curve is the DMSO
negative control showing the target is
denatured has occurred at and then the
red one is using a known potent positive
control inhibitor and this is at each
five eight eight and the TM shift
definitely is to the right and it shows
very good separation between you know
the signal to background all right so
the goal again is to choose the
temperatures for the next step and just
some guidance here you'd want to choose
the lowest temperature and then a couple
of flanking temperatures around this and
that was acceptable and sometimes if you
choose the high temperature this affects
the apparent acidity of the compound
all right so now here is Phase three and
the goal of this phase is the final step
of the main you know assay development
process is to measure the isothermal and
heavier dose response curve so now we're
looking at just you know one to three
different temperatures as determined by
that phase to step on the last slides so
for instance you're going to be looking
at maybe 47 degrees to 57 degrees you
know a very small window design your
plate prepare the positive controls and
now this time instead of a single
concentration you're going to do serial
dilutions and you dispense your
compounds to the plate harvest and
transect yourself set up to assay and
incubate with the compound and then the
main step is performing the isothermal
denaturation types of experiments using
those different temperatures identified
prior you're going to look at these dose
response curves as a function of
temperature to determine the final
conditions so this would be okay let me
look at the IC 50s at this point as well
as the good sa windows do your detection
reaction your readout and analyze the
data and choose your final conditions so
after you're done with this you're
finally happy the main experiment went
well you can go ahead and generate your
stable cell lines or if you want you
know you can definitely continue to do
transient transfection
to test other conditions and targets etc
alright so here's just some
characteristics just to summarize from
the last slide as far as assay windows
you really want them to be above to no
matter what preferably above 3 for
potent you know positive control
inhibitors and you want to confirm that
your rank order potencies you know the
EC 50s or IC 50s for your known
inhibitors are correct so again here's
looking at the control the control the
mth one example and you see that the EC
50s are nice in a good order that
corresponds to the results seen in the
literature for these specific compounds
tested and the assay windows are all
above four so it's very nice obviously
except the control inhibitor which
they lipid kinase the post NHRA steps
for this specific target was about 2.5
minutes long at 48 degrees so that was
the condition used for this control all
right now I'm going to move into the
last section of the talk this is the
application and case study section the
applications were you know kind of
mentioned at the beginning of the talk
and they're kind of summarized here so
obviously you want to establish cellular
permeability something that is not done
through biochemical type of screens and
you want to obtain you know target
engagement of your protein of your
compound of interest you want to verify
cellular activity from hits from you
know your biochemical screen rank order
the compound cellular potencies you know
help this is during like your lead
optimization type of steps analyze the
targets where you know they may be
lacking a simple or direct type of
functional assay that you know obviously
may not be available they're kind of
hard to come by for you know more unique
type of targets you want to establish
the mechanism of action for your
compound you know that was maybe a hit
from a screen to typical screen for
instance for instance a hypothesis of
compound X binding kinase Y and prove
that you get cellular target engagement
maybe you want to de-risk off targets
activities you may have seen you know
your compound from a broad biochemical
type of screen and then all these can be
applicable for many different targets
we've tried hydrolases methyl
transferases and many different kinase
Asst and our customers are trying a lot
more and we'll keep adding this to our
collection to help you with your project
all right so our first example is
looking at Abel one now this is a
tyrosine kinase you know looking you
know maybe volved in leukemia and what's
really nice is you can characterize
different types of inhibitor classes and
what i mean by that is for instance type
1 type of inhibitors they bind to the
active
information of this specific target able
one type two type of inhibitors bind to
inactive confirmations then maybe you're
looking at non ATP competitive
allosteric type of inhibitors so
allosteric inhibitor means it binds to a
non active site location but still
affects the binding let's see so here we
have the statin 'm which is a highly
potent type one type of inhibitor you
know known with cellular activity within
like the single digit nano molar so we
we expected this from you know the
literature to show that it worked
imagine it with another the first drug
approached approved for this specific
target and this is about a hundred nano
molar activity range so we showed this
then we looked at g NF to compound this
compound binds outside of the active
site so it's an allosteric non ATP
competitive effects going on it actually
binds to the myristate type of binding
site so the non ATP binding site of this
specific kinase and then we have our
control headed olympic kinase that was
used in the earlier study now able 1 as
well as that M th one hydrolase we
already have those available as kits
ready to use
we already did all the cloning
transfection etc stable cell line
generation for you if you'd like those
as a test case we do have those
available alright so now we're going to
look at analyzing challenging targets
and that M th one hydrolase is
definitely a challenging target its
interest is in also in cancer inhibitors
basically affect the cell proliferation
and there's very there's a lot of
difficulties building functional assays
for this one and earlier thermo shift
assays were used to prove that the
inhibitors of this enzyme were actually
cell penetrant and engaging so we wanted
to make sure we recapitulated this type
of study and then we have our g9a this
is our first methyl transferase we're
looking at an epigenetic target
definitely difficult to create
functional assays for these and the
readout actually could be very complex
and sometimes requiring math
stack so is nice you know to have a nice
convenient simple cell based targeting
agent assay that you can use to answer
these questions alright so those are
difficult challenging projects now we
have a case study so discover X is
working with the structural genomics
consortium this is based out of North
Carolina site so the SGC is focused on
working on developing potent and
selective chemical probes or inhibitors
for every kinase in the kinam so and I
do realize there's about 500 plus you
know kinase is and only about 15% of
those have dedicated you know well
understood inhibitors so overall this is
a potential goldmine you know remaining
85% of the relevant targets for diverse
disease indications so by determining
these chemical probes or inhibitors will
definitely pave the way for this
specific initiative and proof of the
target engagement is a key specific step
in their and their strategy is shown in
the flow chart so what they do is they
start out you know working with pharma
collaborators get their hands on as many
diverse inhibitors as they can assemble
this set and maybe screen it over using
a biochemical type of a screening
approach they work with us using our
kind of scan biochemical service here
discover X they identified compounds of
a you know 500 or 600 molecule library
for which kind of targets do I have that
are potent and selective inhibitors so
they really did focus on under study
kinases they wanted to you know
ultimately ID them and prove the
molecules and then test them ultimately
in a phenotypic type of screen when
connie's targets are good for specific
diverse disease indications so in
general though the phenotypic screenings
can be very expensive and lengthy so
before they start this step they wanted
to find you know does my compound get
into the cell and engage
my target so this is a key step in
helping them reduce the number of
molecules they moved into the next
phenotypic screening step so let me just
show you two examples gak and has been
kinase a''s and look at their potency
rank orders that they establish and this
is shown in this slide the GAC kinase at
the top has been at the bottom they
successfully ran the assays generated
the rank order potencies obtain sub we
know 100 aníbal
type of levels of concentrations RAC 50s
excuse me
left-to-right it gets less and less
potent so hopefully this shows you the
importance of doing cellular target
engagement especially with kinase is not
only determine if the compounds can
penetrate through the cell but also
looking at it as far as competition with
the cofactors for kinase is specifically
because there's ATP so kinase is all by
an ATP generally competitive with
respect to that inhibitor in most cases
and kinase is have different affinities
for HIV so keep that in mind
so when you're comparing your data your
biochemical data with your new cellular
data there could be a 10 to 100 fold
offset difference between these type of
data so just keep that in line alright
so that was our collaboration with SGC
now we have a GSK poster these two
posters shown here though in general are
from the SLS conference the GSK poster
focused on using cellular thermal shift
type of assay is from set error called
Sesa and they introduced the insult
pulse technology within their
experiments and they made a duygu
high-throughput 384-well type of format
and looked at many different diverse
targets so highly recommend to look at
that the link is at the bottom which I
can definitely share with you later and
then we have our poster that we've done
at the SLS conference as well most of
the data if not all has already been
described in this
or available on our website but I wanted
to focus on a small portion of the right
hand poster where it has a small circle
on it I'll blow that up and it's shown
here so what we did was we took the hi
gnome and we wanted to spread it out and
create you know look at all the targets
throughout the human kind known that
kind of balanced it out the specificity
of human kind when we did we created
about 25 different her we looked at 25
different kinase ha's as shown here on
the table and then we put together this
as a package so if you need any of the
ec50 data's SP you know looking at what
compounds did we use we have this data
for you and a reference set the
kindnesses obviously include
understudied kinases as well as well
studied ones and common off target
kinase is definitely where studied and
these were identified by biochemical
inhibitor selective screens so we have
this data for you and if you need the
expression vectors for any of these
specific targets we can make that
available to as well alright I'm going
to end the talk with a quick summary and
then move right into the Q&A session so
hopefully I was convinced you know with
a roll of cellular target engagement and
you know obviously in the drug discovery
process is ideally very important for
establishing you know whether your
compound can penetrate through the cell
membrane and engage with your specific
target and the cellular context we have
a solution for you it's you know easy to
measure single or simple readout binding
with a chemiluminescent type of readout
as well no custom you know chemical
tracers or antibodies is needed its
provides you know a convenient solution
for you it's definitely a more robust
than many of the solutions out there and
it is an egg product form that's very
generic for a diverse set of targets
you're interested in this is especially
important you know if there's no
functional assays that are available and
it definitely complements biochemical
assays you know if you want to de-risk
off targets identified in these screens
for instance and then obviously you can
use it for a high-throughput screening
as well all right so thank you very much
and I will begin to take any questions
that you may have thank you thank you
dr. Haley Vicente for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click in the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for if you are unable to get to if
we are unable to get to your questions
you will receive a follow-up email after
the presentation so let's get started
our first question is what is the most
important step during the in cell post
essay development well thank you um so
the most important step is probably
looking at all the different variables
you want to focus on the thermal
denaturation stat was being highly
important obviously but I would say the
key step is the cloning you definitely
want to try multiple constructs for the
highest success rate you want to
carefully obviously choose your
reference inhibitors and you don't want
to skip the phase one asset development
part specifically running the positive
control so again designing your
constructs carefully make sure you put
that PL tag on both you know the
n-terminus and then try the c-terminus
don't skip optimizations for readout
conditions so you don't get sensitive
and you want to get a true readout next
question thank you so the next question
is how well does your system work on
full link vs. domains any examples of
full length proteins
oh yeah so I'm
earlier in a slide that they definitely
work for both full length and domains
we've tried both for a lot of the kinase
a--'s specifically so again you'd like
to that you should test both to make
your contracts using a full length or
the domains this is definitely that
critical step maybe focus on a catalytic
domain obviously when it is a
full-length protein for multiple domain
proteins these are these can be
difficult so definitely try a domain
this is a good example of this is that
able one kinase I hope that answers your
questions ok next one thank you can
install pulse be used in higher
throughput formats like 384 well yeah
yes
so that GSK poster was a nice example
where they took the post technology and
they were able to adapt our 96-well
protocol to the 384 well format so yeah
this is definitely applicable and it was
like three slides back ok ok my right ok
and we'll wrap up with one more question
and that question is have you tried to
look at membrane protein targets
so this is that's a good question so we
have several customers who are looking
at a membrane proteins and we do have
this under development in-house as well
it is such a new technology but we
assume that this will probably work
because there are examples of thermal
shift assays that actually you know look
at integral proteins for instance um the
sodium potassium ATPase pump was done
the drugs transporter that MDR 1 was
done we also assume that some NH RS
would probably work really well with
this assay as well so definitely you
know try it try it and you know
obviously our tech support team can help
you get through some troubleshooting
spots if you need to ok
great I would like to once again thank
dr. Haley Vicente for her presentation
do you have any final comments
yeah just if you have my email here feel
free to email me additional questions
that I can you know answer directly to
you or contact our technical support and
again we have a web page also indicated
at the top of the screen for itself you
want to learn more details and thank you
very much for joining the webinar today
thank you thank you once again dr. Haley
Vicente I would also like to thank lab
roots and discover X for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through November 18th
2017 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye